okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about averages
and means so this is definitely
something you want to understand on the
act they usually test this in a couple
different formats let's go through it
the first thing you want to know is the
formula for
the average or the mean the mean is just
another name for the average and so what
you do when you calculate the average is
you total up whatever it is that you're
working with
and you divide by
how many of those that there are and
that's your average now on the ect they
may have you solve for the average they
may have you solve for the number of
items they may have you solve for the
total they may have you solve for one of
the missing quantities so as long as you
know the formula you can substitute in
what you know and solve for the unknown
so let's go through two examples and
you'll get a better feel for how this
works
so the first example is a little bit
more straightforward example it just
says what is the average number of fish
caught by the fishermen and there's a
table over here it's got bob john alex
and sam it shows you the number of fish
that they caught maybe it's like a
fishing competition something like that
and we're just trying to figure out what
the average is so go ahead and pause the
video and go ahead and see if you can
solve it and then we'll go through it
together
okay so the first thing we want to do is
using our average formulas we want to
total up the number of fish caught so
let's go ahead and do that so we've got
let's see 8 plus 2 is 10
okay and 6 plus 4 is 10 so 10 plus 10 is
20. so it's a total of 20. so that's
your total right here divided by how
many people are in this competition
there's four
and so that's going to give you your
average which is 20 divided by four
which means it's five fish on average
per person so the answer is five now
that one was pretty easy let's do a
little bit more challenging one
example number two it says if you have
scored in 87 76 88 and 92
on the last four tests what do you need
to score on the fifth test to have an
overall average of 90. okay now this is
a pretty uh popular question both in
your class as well as on the act people
are wondering what do i need to do to
get up to that to that a minus range
right
so go ahead and see if you can solve
this on your own and we'll come back
together and we'll do it
together okay so basically what you want
to do here is we're still using this
average formula here the average is a
total divided by the number of tests and
in this case your average that you want
is 90. so let's put that in for the
average 90 and then the total is going
to be 87 plus 76
plus 88 plus 92
okay now the fifth test we don't know
what that is so we're just going to call
it
x okay the unknown divided by the total
of how many tests here now some students
will make the mistake of saying well
there's four tests but now when we add
on that fifth test we have a total of
five
okay so then what you want to do now is
you're trying to get the x by itself
that unknown test what you can do is
multiply both sides of the equation by
five okay this is like five over one so
these are going to cancel one another
out
five times 90 is 450
and then let's go ahead and total these
up of course you can use your calculator
so let's do that
87 plus 76 plus 88 plus 92 that's 343
okay
plus x and of course if we subtract 343
from both sides
okay x equals well let's see what does
that come out to that looks like um
let's see let's just do another
calculator real quick minus 343.
it's 107.
so you would definitely have to get the
extra credit right on this this last
test to boost your grade up to a 90. so
again means or averages definitely an
important concept you want to understand
for the act